Israel's defense minister yov galand has
laid out a plan for Gaza ahead of the
meeting by the security cabinet he's
told reporters that Palestinians would
be allowed to govern Gaza as long as
there's no threat to Israel he's also
repeated the Hamas members would not be
involved but Israeli media reporting the
security cabinet meeting descended into
chaos before gallant's plan was
discussed far-right ministers a set of
ended up in a shouting match with the
Army's Chief of Staff about the
investigation into the hamus attack on
October the 7th going to speak to Laura
Khan who's in occupied East Jerusalem
tell us about your gan's plan and what
happened at the
meeting well first of all this is the F
very first framework that's been laid
out about the day after the war in Gaza
and as you said and as Israel has
reiterated time and time again there
will be no Hamas ruling instead there
will be a Palestinian entity and there
was a question whether the Palestinian
Authority that rules some of the
occupied West Bank would be involved but
they want limited involvement from them
but it all comes with pretty big
conditions one of them is that Israel
will maintain a l SE and air blockade
and very tight restrictions and control
over Gaza making the day after seem a
lot like the day before there will also
be an International Coalition which
includes Western Nations and possibly
some Arab Nations taking care of
internal security um so there are many
conditions to Grapple with um but
certainly no Hamas control that's given
now this was going to be presented in a
wider war and security cabinet meeting
that meeting descended into chaos
according to Israeli media um herel Hy
who is the Army Chief of Staff has set
up a probe about this what happened on
October 7th the security issues
surrounding the Hamas offensive but the
people who he's got involved in this pro
has created a big issue for the far
right wing ministers they complained
that these were also involved in the
2005 unilateral pull out of the Israelis
from Gaza and many of them want to see
Israel retake control of Gaza they also
accuse him of bowing down to
International pressure in in creating
this probe during a war they said it
simply shouldn't be happening now but
what we got from Israeli media is they
could hear people could hear shouting
all the way down the corridor and
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu canceled the meeting after 3
hours without even discussing this now
speaking of international pressure
Anthony blinkin at the US Secretary of
State will be coming he will want to
discuss what's going to happen the day
after alongside what's happening in Gaza
currently and whether they will begin to
pull back some troops and create more
surgical operations in a third stage but
also more importantly what's happening
with the captives more of them have died
since he was last here so there will be
certainly many questions yeah Laura stay
with us for a moment we're going to take
a look at what's happening in the
occupied West Bank a 17-year-old
Palestinian has been killed in Bak Rema
that's Northwest of rala as Israeli
raids continue seven other Palestinians
have also been injured the Palestinian
red cresant says two ambulances in Two
Towns have been hit one by rubber
bullets one by live rounds Crews inside
are said to have been injured we'll go
back to Laura so we've been reporting on
the fact that the nor Shams raid has
lasted for about 30 hour well over 30
hours now the raids are still going
on yeah absolutely um now at least uh 30
hours in nor shamps um we know that
there have been Fierce confrontations
there's been snipers on the roof
including of one school um so we will
keep you updated on that we there's no
press allowed inside and we know many
ambulances have been blocked uh now the
the person who was killed in bit Rema um
he is aside Tark Al romawi he was 17
years old uh so this just happened
Northwest of rala we also know there
were many raids happening throughout the
occupied West Bank as we've been seeing
on on a daily basis one was in a balata
refugee camp uh near Navas uh we know
that uh as you said uh ambulances have
been attacked and there's also been some
armed confrontations between
Palestinians there and Israelis and
there's all the way from the north to
the very south there's been raids from
Janine kilia tobas all the way down to
heon and also here in occupied East
Jerusalem and the latest death has put
the toll at 326 Palestinians since uh
October 7th and far more than 5,000
arrests many people held in
administrative detention without charge
or trial Laura thank you very much
that's Laura Khan talking to us from
occupied East Jerusalem